down the rebound  and he stepped out he lost his balance  trying to save that pass that was  slightly off and westbrook  stepped out of bounds it looked like he  maintained his balance saving the ball  but then as he tried to go up court  there would have stepped out but i don't  know look model like a like a  sean elliott i don't know if his heel  was down  on the out of bounds there we'll have to  see on this review play but  reminds me of 2000 when sean elliot  hit that three-pointer and  heals close to the sideline but  can't tell from that angle if he  actually touched it  ooh very close he might have touched it  shawn elliot yes yeah that was 2000  right yeah against the portland  trailblazer right  why'd you have a dinner that night  [Laughter]  [Applause]  russell upset with himself that even got  that close  to the line  [Applause]  yeah i don't know it's tough to tell  there from that  angle i don't know if it's enough to  overturn the call  russ feels like it's enough